tras no exigir molas o mantienes cargo
el presidente ecuatoriano evitó ser
destituido después de que la asamblea no
aprobara una moción de censura propuesta
por el partido del ex presidente rafael
correa y que lo responsabilizaba de la
crisis política que atraviesa el país
tras tres días de debate la iniciativa
recibió 80 de los 92 votos necesarios
unas horas antes las había anunciado la
suspensión del diálogo con los líderes
de los manifestantes por la muerte de un
soldado en un ataque al margen de las
protestas el país ha sido testigo de
todos los esfuerzos que hemos hecho para
entablar un diálogo fructífero y sincero
además hemos dado respuestas concretas a
las demandas de nuestros hermanos
indígenas pero no volveremos a sentarnos
a dialogar con leonidas iza quien solo
defiende sus intereses políticos y no lo
de sus bases leonidas iza lidera la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas la conaie que encabeza las
protestas contra el aumento del coste de
la vida ha dicho que las concesiones del
presidente lazo como la disminución del
precio del combustible no son
suficientes el gobierno rompe el diálogo
confirmando su autoritarismo falta de
voluntad e incapacidad responsabilizamos
a guillermo lasso de las consecuencias
de su política belicista exigimos
respeto para nuestro máximo líder lazo
no rompe con leonidas rompe con el
pueblo el gobierno redujo 10 centavos
del precio de la gasolina y puso fin al
estado de emergencia en ecuador las
anteriores movilizaciones del movimiento
indígena ya provocaron la caída de tres
presidentes entre
mil 5